some breaking news to
bring you now i'm sorry to say that uh
the body
of a man that was found in a lake in
epping forest has
now been identified the identified tea
confirmed
as that of the 19 year old student
richard okoragai
richard went missing from his home in
labrick grove
on monday the 22nd of march his necks of
kin had been informed
richard's death is being treated as
unexplained this is according to
metropolitan police and police do not
believe at this stage
that there was any third party
involvement
i've got a statement to bring you now
from detective superintendent danny
gosling who said my deepest sympathies
go out to richard's family at this
incredibly difficult time
this was not the outcome that any of us
had hoped for and we will ensure that
his grieving family are well supported
by specially trained officers i would
like to extend my thanks to the many
officers staff and members of the public
who've each played a part in the
extensive effort to locate
richard and of course that investigation
into the circumstances
of richard's corridor of richard
kuragai's death
is ongoing further such as being carried
out